c'est aujourd'hui qu'entre en vigueur la
taxe d'accise désormais imposées sur les
vins canadiens c'est un fardeau de plus
pour les vignerons qui doivent déjà
composer avec plusieurs défis la
fédérale 2 166 millions de dollars
annoncés hier à l'industrie sera t elle
suffisante on va discuter tout ça avec
l'érection et les propriétaires du
vignoble pinard et filles à magog
bonsoir monsieur simon
bonjour alors on va commencer en parlant
de cette taxe qui va s'élever bon entre
22 69 cents par litre de vin les
vignerons en étaient exemptés depuis
2006 qu'il n'est pas quel impact pensez
vous que cela aura sur l'industrie cette
nouvelle taxe qui entre en vigueur
en fait ça fait une taxe d'environ 50
sous la bouteille
moi je veux c'est vraiment plus haut
niveau de la lourdeur administrative de
devoirs
avec tout ce qu'on a à faire à devoir en
plus remplir la paperasserie par les
calculs envoyer les chèques idéalement
porter parce que j'imagine qu'on va être
pénalisé
c'est sûr que ultime mais avec tout ce
qui augmente les matières sèches
maintenant à theix d'assises
éventuellement c'est sûr que quelqu'un
va devoir payer la facture ça risque
d'être le consommateur ah oui donc parce
que on estime que pour l'industrie la
savoie représenter cette taxe n'a à peu
près 135 millions de dollars sur deux
ans hier le gouvernement fédéral a dit
que avec son nouveau programme de
soutien à l'industrie ses 166 millions
de dollars qui sera versé aux
producteurs une annonce qui intervient
la veille de l'entrée en vigueur de la
taxe or on dit que c'est pas pour
éponger cette taxe est ce que c'est un
hasard selon vous
qu'est ce que vous en pensez on pourrait
dire que le hasard fait bien les choses
dans ce cas-ci où l'agent n'existe paul
cessé selon
la difficulté que j'ai avec l' annonce
c'est
on n'est pas aux attaques racistes pour
répondre à au droit international de
commencer nationale par rapport à la à
l'australie et là on vient dans le fond
le grenat va nous compenser exact à peu
près exactement le même montant que
l'australie à tout ce que tu as le texte
à 6,9 vont leur apporter donc j'ai
l'impression qu'on tourne un peu
problème je ne sais pas comment ça va ça
va rebondir
parce que bon les producteurs canadiens
on était exempté de cette taxe depuis
2006 l'australie s'est plaint il ya eu
défaite du canada devant l'organisation
mondiale du commerce et leur on essaie
un peu de rattraper par la bande c'est
ce que j'entends mais officiellement le
gouvernement dit cette somme là c'est
pour aider les producteurs à innover
investir dans leurs installations se
prémunir contre certains risques les
changements climatiques par exemple ce
que vous pensez ou si vous en
particulier que les vignerons vont
utiliser ces sommes là à cet effet
oui en fait il
s'est passé pas excessivement
subventionner l'agriculture
est revenir au québec ça représente
énormément de défis on était dans une
entreprise qui est en pleine croissance
les 26 québec ont vraiment la cote c'est
sûr que d'avoir de l'aide
gouvernementale pour pallier à tous les
défis dont fait face dans une saison
c'est sûr que c'est le bienvenu
je pense que les vignerons vont
probablement utilisé l'argent pour
s'équiper davantage ou améliorer
certaines pratiques et non pas pour
éponger la tasse titubant cet exercice
va être refilée aux clients de toute
façon c'est parce que vous évoquiez
toutes sortes de pressions qu'elle vous
fait face en ce moment la hausse des
coûts des matières premières roses du
transport et tous les problèmes dans la
chaîne d'approvisionnement à quel point
ça comprime vos marges en ce moment est
ce que c'est la différence entre la
rentabilité et ne prêtent pas à être
rentable
mais c'est ce que le coût des matières
premières et d'oubli donc les verts les
lieux les bouteilles de verre continue
est tout simplement doublé les délais
sont excessivement longs
nous on est quand même privilégié dans
l'industrie dans la mesure où notre
tarification est peut-être un petit peu
au-delà ou déçu de certains collègues
mais c'est soit un impact si c'est me
séparer premièrement le double
manifestement c'est la moitié moins
d'argent qu'on a pour continuer à
grandir à investir ou
avancez
l'essence un impact chaque hausse les
salaires ont monté beaucoup cette année
donc c'est sûr qu'il ya un impact majeur
mais surtout les secteurs en entreprise
au canada voire en amérique du nord
ressentent la même chose là on va
terminer sur une bonne nouvelle monsieur
simon vous me disiez le vin québécois à
la cote et les récoltes ont été somme
toute assez bonne l'an dernier alors les
récoltes est ce qu'on espère que ce sera
bon cette année et la demande va être au
rendez vous selon vous
d'où la demande de rendez-vous la saison
et les magnifiques je pense que le sage
les à ma connaissance nulle part au
québec cette année ce qui est
pratiquement exceptionnel le musée mais
difficile on de travail est vraiment
vraiment fort à la vigne il ya beaucoup
de pression au niveau des maladies mais
on se lève d'un millésime magnifique
2021 ce qu'on a en cas parce qu'on aura
à vendre cette année les vins sont
exceptionnelles pour le mans les plus
beaux vins qu'on a fait en dix ans donc
l'avenir est rose bon ben on vous
souhaite une bonne saison et on veut
lever un verre à votre
merci infiniment pour voir nos émissions
en entier rendez vous sur la chaîne ici
et redit